William is with us in Pittsburgh hey
William welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I was calling my wife and
I have been working on the baby steps
for about six months now and we're at a
point where we're deciding on if we
should sell our house to pay off some of
our student loan debt do you like your
house yeah this Nora forever home I know
no such thing yeah no one lives in a
home forever unless they're just
resistant to change the so how much debt
do you have not counting your home
not counting the house we have seventy
four thousand which is all student loans
and how much equity do you have in your
home about sixty thousand okay and what
is your household income okay
so you've worked the debt snowball down
to the one big debt and he kind of hit
the wall emotionally right yeah yeah
that makes sense
a good job how much have you paid off so
far well we had like some money in our
savings that we were able to pay along
with a gift from a family member so we
were able to pay off probably about
$18,000 so far okay but how much of that
was gift and the savings five thousand
was a gift in probably about I want to
say six thousand was from savings okay
that means you personally have cash
floats seven thousand dollars in debt
reduction yeah and what period of time
way I said about five or six months okay
and you make $90,000 a year yes okay
your house isn't the problem your
lifestyles are problem
people who make $90,000 a year doing a
debt-free screen here on the air if you
listen to them usually pay off the to
the tune of thirty to fifty thousand
dollars a year is the rate at which they
are reducing debt on average now that
means they're on a scorched-earth
lifestyle beans and rice rice and beans
no vacations Christmas is a craft and
you don't see the inside of a restaurant
less you're working there but you're
getting out of debt you have not been on
that budget with $7,000 paid off in five
months
no not yet that's not the same rate of
reduction so you know what I would say
is this moving is very expensive
financially and emotionally and
physically it's expensive and so I would
move as a last resort unless you just
already hate your house and if you hate
your house and you want to move you know
you just go rent for a little while or
something but I think instead what you
guys have got to do is turn the screws
up on this budget turn the heat up on
this budget and you know just take your
life and say we want to be out of debt
more than we want X or Y or Z for a
short period of time because if you paid
off $30,000 a year for two years you
would be debt-free
but that's $2,500 a month not $800 a
month so you need to turn it up by about
4x to get to that rate of reduction but
that would put you about the typical
debt-free screen very few people William
can wander out of debt
most people have to get so personally
angry about the debt or scared about the
debt that they cut deeply into their
former way of doing things and then you
change things so hey thank you for the
call